IN LONG.
THESE GUYS TOLD ME THAT IT'S NOT
ONLY ABOUT THE PLAYOFFS AT THIS
DEFENSIVE SIDE YEAR.
TRAVIS KONECNY WILL TAKEYED AND.
EARLY OPPORTUNITY SANHEIM.
DEFENSEMEN CARRIES BACK IN FROM
PHILADELPHIA.
DOWN THE RIGHT SIDE.
CE
GOOD.
NEAR HAS THE STARS PENALTY
KILLING THOUGH.
>> Josh: STARS WERE JUST
SHORTHANDED ONEOUT,
PHILLIES MAKING A
KLINGBERG, TO THE CENTER OF THE
ZONE.
RIGHT SIDE IN SKATES.
SUTER THE LEAD. THOSE.
5 ON 5, PRETTY MU
FINAL BULLET DODGED BY THE STARS
IN THE CLOSING SECONDS AND CALGS
.
>> Josh: ESPECIALLY WHEN IT'S
BEEN CALLED IN THE GAME A CHANC
ENDS IN THE 4 OFEIR OWN ZONE.
THEY WENT RIGHT BACK WIDE.
COUTURIER, SENDS IT AROUND.
RISTOLAINEN IS LOOKING FOR A HA.
BUMPED RIGHT BACK IN AND PAST
WITH MORE THAN HE WANTED TO AND
LEAD.
>> Daryl: THEY GO RIGHT BACK ON
SITUATION LIKE THIS.
THEY CALLED IT DEPTH THAT THEY
HAVE IN THIS SIDE OF THEIR
FACT
HINTZ AS HE GETS IT CIRCLE.
UP HIGH FOR PROVOROV.
BACK FOR BENN AND
LUKE GLENDENING UP TOP TRYING TO
KEEP THAT SHOOTING
THEN BLOWN DEAD OFF SIDE AT THET
>> Daryl: WELL THE CENTERING
FEED WAS FULL